-Letitia Wright. Thanks so much for coming on.
I'm very -- Everyone is very excited about "Black Panther,"
the sequel.
"Black Panther: Wakanda Forever."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The trailer -- By the way, the trailer got
172 million views in just the first 24 hours.
-Yeah. -It, like, broke the Internet.
-Yeah, it did. -It's unbelievable.
I'm so excited about this.
And you unfortunately got injured
while you were shooting this film.
-Yes. -And you look okay now.
Are you doing better? -Yeah.
It was just an unfortunate situation that happened,
but it took me out for, like, three months.
So I went home. I got my mind back together.
I got my healing back together.
And I went back and I finished strong.
So if you want to see how that turned out, November 11th.
-Yeah! Exactly right. You finished it.
I'm so happy. I'm glad you're better.
-Thank you. -What can we -- What can you
tell us about "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever"?
-Well, firstly I can tell you,
you know, the first movie did so well.
You know, we made a cultural impact and change.
-You did. -And this film is --
We're trying to follow that -- that same theme,
you know, of inspiring, you know,
everybody that goes to see it.
We have new cast members,
such as Dominique Thorne, Michaela Coel.
So it's jam-packed with lots of adventures.
But it -- I feel, for me,
it's a beautiful contribution to Chadwick's legacy.
I feel like it's a love letter to him.
I know every day that I went on set, I focused my energy
on -- on each scene to dedicate it to him.
I wanted to dedicate excellence to this film
so that he could be proud.
-Yeah. Oh, I love that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We loved him. Oh, my goodness.
I cannot wait. I can't wait. -Yes.
-Do we know who will be the new Black Panther?
-Okay. Yo, Quest, somebody, come get your man.
[ Laughter ]
-No. You can't --
-I am sworn to secrecy. -Of course.
-By the Marvel spies that are around here somewhere.
-Yeah, they're in the aud--
I just thought maybe you could just give us...
[ Drum roll ]
No. Okay.
-November 11th. -Alright.
November 11th, we're going to find out.
I don't want to -- I don't want to get you in trouble.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Let's talk about your movie, though, "The Silent Twins."
-Yes. -What a great story this is.
-Yeah. -Oh, my gosh.
You're fantastic in it. -Thank you.
-It's based on a true story. -Mm-hmm.
-How did you hear about this? -I heard about the twins
by watching a documentary years ago.
And I was so intrigued.
And I always wondered if it would ever be made into a film.
Fortunately for me, that became true,
and I got to greenlight the film.
I got to star in it and produce it.
-Look at you. Look at you now.
Come on. Look at you.
-And it's a beautiful story
about twin sisters, June and Jennifer Gibbons.
They grew up in the '70s in Wales.
Unfortunately, they had a terrible experience
of racial injustice, marginalization,
and they used silence as a way
to protest against how society made them feel.
And unfortunately, that led to them being placed
into a psychiatric hospital for 11 years.
And our film -- our film takes a deep dive
into the wonderful world
that they created in secrecy to survive.
It's a rich world of creativity, and I'm so proud of it.
-Because they would talk to each other?
-Yeah, just to each other.
And to everyone else, they were silent.
And they thought it was a mystery,
but our film unlocks a little bit more about why they --
they were the way they were.
-Ah, it's fascinating. I want to show a clip.
Here's Letitia Wright in "The Silent Twins."
Take a look at this.
-Jenny!
-Did it arrive? -Yeah!
[ Both chuckle ]
-"The Art of Conversation."
-How do you open it?
-Push. And lift.
[ Gasps ]
-We're writers now. -We're writers now.
-Yeah. You're writers now. Come on.
Letitia Wright, everybody.
"The Silent Twins" opens in theaters tomorrow.
David Blaine joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody. Come on back.